¿Es 3, -4 una solución de la ecuación
"5x" más "2y" igual a 7?
Hay dos maneras de hacer esto
la primera es sustituir estos valores
de "x" y "y "en la ecuación
y ver si la satisface eso,
es lo que vamos a hacer primero.
Y la otra manera es
si tienes la gráfica de esta ecuación,
puedes ver si este punto se encuentra sobre
la gráfica de la ecuación
lo cual va a significar
que es solución de la ecuación.
Hagamos el primer método,
tenemos la ecuación "5x" más  "2y" igual a 7
entonces tenemos
5 multiplicado por "x"
en este caso "x" es igual a 3,
ese va a ser el valor de "x"
entonces va a ser 5 por 3
más
vamos a sumarle,
dos veces el valor de "y"...
dos veces el valor de "y" que es -4
más dos veces -4
y esto tiene que ser igual a 7
queremos verificar si esto se cumple
bien,
hagamos las operaciones del lado izquierdo
del lado izquierdo tenemos,
5 por 3 es 15
luego 2 por -4 es -8
entonces esto sería 15 menos 8
y tenemos que verificar que
15 menos 8 sea igual a 7
y efectivamente 15 menos 8 es igual a 7,
así es que esto se cumple y la respuesta es sí,
sí es solución de la ecuación.
Hemos encontrado la solución
por el método de sustitución
vamos a graficar la ecuación
para encontrar la solución por el método gráfico.
Hagamos entonces la gráfica,
lo que voy a hacer
es una tabla de valores
hay varias maneras
de encontrar la gráfica
podríamos poner esta ecuación
en la forma punto pendiente
pero lo que yo voy a hacer
es una tabla de valores
"x" y "y",
los cuales graficaré
y veremos si el punto 3, -4
se encuentra sobre la recta
podríamos graficar
directamente el punto 3, -4
y vamos a ver que
efectivamente se encuentran sobre la recta
ya vimos que es una solución,
pero no lo voy a hacer por el momento,
simplemente voy a dar
valores para obtener una gráfica,
así entonces si "x" es igual a 0,
5 por 0 es igual a 0
más 2 por "y" igual a 7
si 2 por "y" es igual a 7,
"y" tiene que ser 3.5
2 por 3.5 es igual a 7,
así es que "y" es igual a 3.5
3.5,
tomemos ahora
el valor de "x" igual a 1,
si "x" es igual a 1 aquí tenemos
5 por 1 más 2 por "y" es igual a 7
a ver veamos 5 más "2y"  igual a 7
pasamos el 5 restando el otro lado
"2y" es igual a 2, "y" va a ser igual a 1
cuando "x" es igual a 1,
"y" es igual a 1
Ahora hagamos "x"...
hagamos "x" igual...
bueno, de hecho con estos
dos puntos podemos graficar la recta
podríamos tener más puntos de hecho
podemos tener el punto 3, -4 aquí
pero con estos dos puntos
ya es suficiente para poder graficar
grosso modo una recta
así es que hagamos nuestro eje "x"
y aquí vamos a tener nuestro eje "y"
nuestro eje vertical que es nuestro eje "y"
vamos a poner la escala
aquí tenemos 1, 2, 3, 4
y -1, -2, -3, -4
y vamos a poner nuestra escala para "x"
tendríamos 1... esa esta muy grande,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6...
esto es para "x"
vamos a graficar entonces los puntos,
el punto 0, 3.5
0, 1, 2, 3, 3.5...
aquí está...
y el punto 1,1...
el punto 1,1 que tenemos por aquí
y así ya puedo construir la recta,
lo voy a hacer con una línea punteada
para conectar más fácilmente los puntos,
déjame hacerlo mejor,
déjame hacer mejor la recta
construimos entonces
nuestra línea recta,
de tal manera que podemos checar
si el punto 3, -4 está en la recta
para esto necesito trazar una mejor recta
voy a tomar una nueva oportunidad
de trazar una mejor recta
vamos entonces
a trazar una mejor recta
de tal manera que aquí tenemos
vamos a hacer un mejor trabajo con esto,
de tal manera,
que al conectar los puntos tenemos la recta
entonces si quiero ver si el punto 3, -4
se encuentra sobre la recta
ubicó "x" igual a 3
y veo si sobre la recta
a un valor de "x" igual a 3
corresponde un valor de "y" igual a -4
y efectivamente tenemos el punto 3, -4
obviamente en general no vas a confiar
simplemente en la inspección de la gráfica
quizás al ver la gráfica tú ves un
valor de "y" de -3.99
por lo cual te quedaría duda
con tan sólo ver la gráfica
es por eso que tienes que ir
directamente a la ecuación
para que cuando sustituyes
los valores de "x" y "y"
verificas que se cumple la igualdad
no tan sólo por ver la gráfica
pero es importante darse cuenta
que la gráfica es otra representación
de todas las soluciones de esta ecuación.